zwei promi würde liegen tot in einem
verbarrikadierten keller einer pizzeria
in stuttgart die leichen übel
zugerichtet und die ermittler stehen vor
einem rätsel was passiert sein könnte es
sind alles wie ein krimi
jan iv 53 jahre besitzer des edel
italieners und geschäftsführer rosario l
sind tot das ist traurige tatsache was
genau passiert ist im restaurant vale in
der geschwister-scholl-straße in
stuttgart ist allerdings noch völlig
unklar nach einem zeugenhinweis gestern
gegen 15.50 sind unsere kollegen in die
geschwister scholl straße gefahren haben
dort im untergeschoss des gebäudes in
einem zimmer zwei tote männer gefunden
im alter von 53 jahren beide leichen
wiesen schwere verletzungen auf nach
einer ersten gerichtsmedizinischen
begutachtung sind diese verletzungen bei
beiden durch scharfe gewalt entstanden
die leichen der beiden männer sollen
extrem brutal zugerichtet worden sein
bild erfuhr feuerwehr und polizei
mussten das kellerzimmer aufbrechen die
tür war von innen verriegelt hinter der
tür eine riesige blutlache vermutlich
hatten sich die beiden 53 jährigen
männer gegenseitig mit messern bekämpft
bis aufs blut bis in den tod wir müssen
eben morgen auch das ergebnis der
obduktion abwarten um hinweise zu
bekommen wie die tat abgelaufen ist
derzeit werden weitere personen aus dem
umfeld der beiden toten befragt und die
gesichter die gesicherten spuren von
gestern werden weiter ausgewertet das
motiv bisher reine spekulation jan iv
und sein bruder giuseppe besaßen mehrere
italienische restaurants in besten lagen
in stuttgart im edlen per baku wechselte
erst vor wenigen wochen der pächter
möglich dass es auch neue pläne mit dem
vale gab war ein geschäftlicher streit
der grund für das tödliche gemetzel im
keller wenn sich zeugen
zur verfügung stellen dann sollen sie
sich an die kriminalpolizei wenden jan
iv und rosario m 2 große namen in der
stuttgarter gastroszene jetzt sind sie
tot ein bizarrer doppelmord unter höchst
mysteriösen umständen
[Musik]